well let me ask the
one last uh ridiculous uh
uh subjective question what's the
greatest plane ever made
in history
speed i would say sr-71 i think it's an
engineering marvel that was actually
developed in the 50s by kelly johnson
you know skunk works
uh for what that was able to do and then
when you get into history of it you know
how they actually
built uh the cia actually made like
six companies in order to buy the
titanium from russia
to bring it back and build an airplane
out of titanium that we would fly over
russia
to me that's it's an incredible
engineering marvel i think
that like the x-15 you know by the way
this sr sorry to interrupt sr-71
still holds the the speed record
for of any plane as far as i can
understand
yeah what's funny when you get into it
is it's remember fast is relative and
when i say that i mean
so if you're going 3 000 miles an hour
100 feet above the ground you're going 3
000 miles an hour
through you know that's how fast you're
going when you get up to altitude
there's an indicated airspeed and
there's a you know
your ground speed so your indicated
airspeed is really
how fast the air is going past your
airplane well the air is so thin up
there
you may only be showing like 300 knots
but at 300 knots you're really doing
2500 miles an hour over the ground so
you know like we would take the
airplanes up to 50 000 feet when we had
to do full
the maintenance check flights on them so
when you're doing 200
you know and you know some mod notch
it's actually slow for the airplane it's
you know you're getting you know it's
kind of like it's not you know there's
maneuvering speeds
you know that if i hit a certain speed
and a super hornet that i have the full
capability of the airfoil
if i'm below that speed i'm going to
stall the airfoil before i get to the
maximum g
okay so when you look at something like
that you go well is it really going
fast and when you look at an sr 71
that's flying upwards of you know
70 plus thousand feet the air so thin
you know just like the x-15 you can get
to a much higher
speed but the relative speed of the air
going over you is actually relatively
low
so the stresses on the airframe are not
like they would be if you were down low
but because you're going fast to get
enough air over your pitot static system
to show that you're going 300 knots
you're you're screaming
i mean the fastest i ever got was i was
with the
uh little soon to be vice admiral white
so we had taken a check flight and uh
and i got it up to 1.78 i got a super
horn up to mach 1.78 and it was
and we were destroyed by pebble beach
too and then it what's that feel like or
is it
when you get that fast it start to me it
got a little bit weird because you
realize
in your brain and i did that there's no
out
if something happens i can't eject the
ejection would kill me
isn't that kind of liberating in a way
um
or no that okay maybe not always want to
push the limit you know it's like how
fast i could have got it going faster
it was it was literally still
accelerating when i stopped but i had it
was fuel limited
and space limited because i you know i'm
off the coast of california
big sur and i'm going and i can see
pebble beach out in the distance uh you
know the whole monterey peninsula just
going and you're doing almost 18 miles a
minute
i mean you're screaming yeah i mean
that's and then you have to turn well
the airplane didn't have anything on it
it was a slicked-off super hornet so it
was basically just the airplane no
pylons no pods no nothing
and then we had to get it turned around
because we got to go to the exit point
for the area and i'm trying to get it
down below
to subsonic and there's a bunch of
things that are disabled like the speed
brakes that normally we pop out when
you're going that fast they don't
because the super
really doesn't have speed brakes it
deforms the flight controls
they don't function so you really you're
trying to maneuver and when you're going
that fast
you can't turn because a 7g turn at 1.5
mach is a pretty big turn
um so it's just it's crazy it's
incredible that a human can do this
yes uh human can engineer that the
system which allows another human to
control that system
it's to me it's it's uh i think it's
just
it's one it's a great experience was it
sad to see the sr-71 go
i think it was during your career i mean
do you
do you guys romanticize the different
planes um we would see it flying when i
was flying hornets because we
the west coast flies in it's called
r2508 which is covers the
navy china lake area and edwards it's a
huge area it's
it's actually i think the we had a guy
from switzerland come out because they
were they had hornets and he's like this
is bigger than our whole country
now because it's a pretty big area in
california that you fly
um but you would see the sr-71s they had
a loop because nasa was flying them
out of palmdale and they would take off
and they'd go up towards washington
state and montana and they'd do a loop
and so you'd see them coming back down
they'd descend out of you know above 60
000 you'd see them either get contrails
you know the white
lines behind airplanes they'd come down
and hit the tanker and they'd go back up
so
it was cool to be able to see them in my
lifetime flying uh
but uh you know i think with money
age um the advent of satellites
you know because they're everywhere now
i mean you've got commercial companies
putting satellites up
uh how much of that need was really
there because you gotta remember when
those things started in the 50s sputnik
wasn't flying around
you know it was it was the u2 and the
sr-71 that were out there doing that
work
um so at the time it was needed it was
at the if you think about it really it
was an incredible feat of aviation for
that time
yeah i mean literally we have yet to
pass that and you also ask well is there
a need to pass that i go i don't know we
got stuff in space so
do we need to make an airplane that goes
that fast i think the next one is you
get into the hypersonics where you don't
have to put a person in it does all
kinds of crazy stuff you know the work
with automation all that kind of stuff
you